to present the Oscar for the Best
Foreign Language Film we have an
internationally distinguished actor who
is uniquely qualified for that road he's
traveled all over the world on behalf of
the United Nations on behalf of children
on behalf of laughter but we managed to
catch him while he was on a goodwill
mission to Hollywood we just flew here
for a few days from Europe where he's
filming with Katharine Hepburn ladies
and gentlemen hiding behind the beard he
grew fur his current film role here is
Danny Kaye
the universal language these days is
really not Esperanto it's filled and the
most articulate spokesman are those who
touch all men with their art regardless
of what tongue is heard on the
soundtrack
now the nominations for the best foreign
language film are chosen from a list of
entries submitted by the countries where
the production's originate and the five
finalists are closely watched trains
from czechoslovakia el amor Brujo from
spain I even met happy gypsies from
Yugoslavia live for life from France and
portrait of Chico from Japan sir the
winner is Czechoslovakia for closely
watched train
excepting for I even that happy gypsies
Alexander Petrovich
I am very happy that Americans like
check field